with the reveal of the Xbox series X we
saw what it actually looks like and
you're probably wondering how the hell
am I gonna fit it in my living room and
what does it look like compared to other
consoles well lucky for you we mopped up
one of our own it's our child the Xbox
box sea wees X this is this is this is
it this is the concept no it's not what
are you talking about this is one that I
like brick this is one I built out of
cardboard so I used the the renders as a
jumping-off point and it looked like it
was about one controller wide one
controller deep and that three
controllers stacked on top of each other
tall is that what they told us no is
that just our own assumption now we have
we have a ton of exclusive details on
games watch calm but the size is just
purely based off of a rendered so this
is not the final dimensions of it this
is just a rough estimate can you lay
this on its side yeah like that like
this yeah that's it and then bigger
question is how old relax how will this
fit in the midst of all my other
consoles so this is GameSpot's
entertainment system setup so let's
actually see how the Xbox series acts
fits with these other concepts well I
mean these are all the same size okay
how does they work on its side though
one thing you need to remember though is
that the vent is at the top something so
this thing this would be nice is you got
all the hot air just pushing up right
there and then if you lay it this way
got all that hot air pushing that way so
it's a tight so the question is can we
fit it like we you're dead
whoa whoa I know what's best like okay
but like doesn't work like we could do
this work I would do it like that I
guess except wait where is all the cards
if I gonna be in the back when this
thing actually comes out and we're gonna
fit it and our wonderful collection of
video game entertainment systems it is
kind of a question of how is this thing
gonna exist in this particular palette
of colors so now we have the family tree
of Xboxes mm-hmm the series of X boxes
well we have do G and then we have the
first iteration of the xbox 360 which is
kind of like the odd-looking duck of the
bunch we got then we skip skip a few we
skip a few iterations we go to the
quintessential Xbox one version it's
just 1x Xbox yeah and then we have the
Xbox series X mock-up that's how it's
gonna stack with the rest of the family
I think one thing our mock-up doesn't
have is whether the disk drives gonna be
but I'm just gonna base on what we saw
I'm gonna estimate it's gonna be about a
right I don't know here yeah okay let's
make a disk drive baby oh wow this is
some heavy-duty cardboard oh there it is
yeah just drive
oh how to make a disk drive was good
what am i doing what am i doing oh yeah
that's right I'm doing me
smash core tennis pro tournament wait a
minute this is a blue game let's even
play ball let's see if it goes yeah it
works kind of fit Namco Museum yeah how
about Namco Museum 250th anniversary
that's a long time this is about right
in terms the size of this is a disk
drive yeah if it's working it's working
I did pretty good job right it's Oh
seems to be going okay there's got this
sweet errors boy whoa baby
that this comes out on the bottom which
is a really interesting feature and it's
okay so if you want to inject them
II a sports it's in the game next
holiday Xbox series X will lead us into
the future of console gaming
Happy Easter Xbox
[Music]